>> CHRIS: IT'S TIME TO PLAY
AMAZON BOOK FAIR: JOB FAIR
EDITION.
THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
SAYS UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN AND
FOR THE SECOND STRAIGHT MONTH,
JOB NUMBERS ARE THE BEST THEY'VE
BEEN IN SEVEN YEARS.
HEAR THAT, @MIDNIGHT VIEWERS?
BRUSH OFF THOSE CHEETOS CRUMBS,
OR AS I LIKE TO CALL IT,
"UNEMPLOYMENT DUST," AND GET A
GODDAMN JOB.
SO COMEDIANS, IN HONOR OF THE
FACT THAT AMERICANS ARE BACK TO
WORK, WE'RE GOING TO SHOW YOU A
BUNCH OF VOCATIONAL BOOKS ABOUT
SOME OF OUR MOST TIME HONORED
PROFESSIONS.
FOR 250 POINTS GIVE ME A CHAPTER
IN THE BOOK.
FIRST ONE: "TOP TEN MISTAKES
PASTORS MAKE."
>> "KIDS SAY THE MOST SEDUCTIVE
THINGS."
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ALEX.
>> CHAPTER 2: "YEAH, BUTT STUFF
COUNTS."
>> CHRIS: MR. PROOPS.
>> CHAPTER 7, WHY IT'S WRONG TO
ASK A YOUNG BOY TO BE ON YOUR
STAFF.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> THAT'S FROM THE BOOK OF
BOOTY-RONOMY.
I GUESS THE CROWD WAS A LITTLE
TOUCHY ABOUT THAT ONE.
I GUESS BUTT STUFF IS REALLY
[BEEP] TASTEFUL.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE.
"AN AMAZING JOURNEY INSIDE MY
MOUTH.
JUST ME AND MY DENTIST."
ALEX BORSTEIN.
>> CHAPTER 5, BECAUSE YOUR WIFE
WON'T GO ON THAT JOURNEY
ANYMORE.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE: "HOW TO BE A
DOLL DETECTIVE: ELEMENTARY
CLUES TO SOLIVING THE MYSTERIES
OF DOLLS."
LIVING DOLL SAMM LEVINE, WHAT'S
YOUR ANSWER?
>> HOW TO LEAVE A NOTE FOR
WHEN YOU'RE EATEN BY YOUR CATS.
>> CHRIS: THEY WILL EAT YOU.
>> THEY WILL.
CHRIS: GREG PROOPS.
>> THIS IS FROM THE FOREWORD:
"THIS IS GONNA MAKE YOU SO SAD."
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> NOW THE MYSTERY IS SOLVED I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH MY
LIFE OR MY NIGHTS.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE AN AMAZING
JOURNEY.
>> I'M SORRY, WHERE?
>> INSIDE YOUR MOUTH.
>> CHRIS: OH! SOLD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MOVING ON, "THE POLE POSITION:
IS STRIPPING FOR YOU? AND HOW TO
STAY HEALTHY DOING IT."
>> CHAPTER 7 WHEN TO PUT DOWN
THE LITTLE CARPET.
>> CHRIS: ALEX.
>> CHAPTER 6: GETTING OUT OF
JOHN MAYER'S TRUNK.
[LAUGHING]
>> IT ALSO SAYS "LOOK INSIDE"
ABOVE THE BOOK.
THAT'S EXTRA.